streaming ist gestartet
kommt vorbei ich habe keine ahnung was
wir hier mal hallo freunde kopiert
ja hallo hallo matte schickte schnellen
links hallo hallo o
das sind sogar schon leute da hallo es
tut mir leid dass wir natürlich zu spät
waren das war ja auch nicht anders
erwarten könnt ihr uns hören online ich
bin online als haben ja viele leute
wundern sich schon dadurch stieg die
ganz schnell den link hier tolle leute
ist ja wirklich der wahnsinn dass hier
endlich freunde es tut mir sehr leid ich
bin ja nicht gerne
ja ich bin sehr verplant was das hier
angeblich das noch nie gemacht habe aber
das läuft jetzt ich muss noch schnell
hier den link rausschicken
und so könnt ihr mal ganz kurz schreiben
ob das vom sound her und vom bild her
und von der musik lautstärke passt
ziemlich verzögert das ganze okay im
moment
ich werde das schnell ändern josefshaus
er will das jetzt ändern
ok freunde einen moment
zum glück
so ihr müsst mir jetzt gleich mal sagen
wie ich das hier macht auto läuft so 30
punkten also echt ja ich okay dann stell
kurzen delay von wie für millisekunden
meinte 200 hallo freunde natürlich muss
rollen tief halten
jana ist in bottrop videos musik oder
videos anschauen so manche dieses jetzt
funktioniert besser freunde ihr müsst
mir sagen ob es jetzt besser geworden
ist
echt
also das ist weniger geworden geworden
okay aber der turm ist schneller
ok dann mache ich noch mehr es ist das
beste das es nicht funktioniert was
meinste wie weit sind wir noch hinten
eine sekunde echt ich mache 3,5
so kostet 2 es ist professional hier
aber so muss das sein weil sonst wäre es
auch um authentische scheiße kinder
hallo um die zeit zu überbrücken könnte
die aber schon mal ganz schnell
irgendwelche fragen reinstellen die
keinen interessieren was ihr passiert ja
schneidet die musik video ganz genau ich
probiere ich mich dahin nicht verzögern
das lange zögern und ich lerne für eine
klausur die ich übermorgen schreibe
finde ich bisher noch nicht allzuviel
gemacht habe deshalb werde ich hier auch
bald wieder verschwinden aus halo die
ist nicht da die ist leider am drehen
und ab
er hatte leider den tag doppelt geplant
deswegen
ist nicht immer verzögert warum ist mag
so inaktiv gute frage warum lässt landet
direkt wieder hochgradig ich bin ich bin
sehr beschäftigt ich habe tatsächlich
ein video fertig geschnitten und ich
weiß ja durch das heute fließen kann
weil ich muss noch ein paar finishing
touches machen lieber morgen und wenn
künftig in klausur ist ein echter trio
gerade bei mir hier nicht natürlich auch
zwei werben die die es bald werd ich
auch nicht normal wieder hochtreiben
würde weil ich ja nicht nur wehren will
das heißt krieg krieg video perfekt ist
es nach wie vor verzögert könnt ihr mir
das bitte sagen die kleine schwester von
meinem mann hat alle ihre kuscheltiere
dave getaucht naja das kann nicht sein
hey man es tut mir übel slide das
übrigens die scheiße hier
ich muss mich vielleicht mal mit irgend
jemandem zusammen tun der ein bisschen
ahnung davon hat weil ich mache das hier
alles so irgendwie freestyle so wie
immer alles hallo hallo hallo hallo
hallo hallo hallo ok damals noch mehr
ich habe schon bin schon bei sechs
sekunden
so und jetzt wird es besser wird es
besser was arbeitest du gar nichts
gefühlt
[Gelächter]
bei mir steht nicht mal werbung unter
meinen post also ich mach ab und zu so
foto und video aufträge und damit halte
ich mich so ein bisschen über wasser ich
bin ja student nicht für ein relativ
kleines leben war dieses jahr nur auf 15
reisen
naja war das läuft alles
wenn ich unterwegs bin mache ich
meistens irgend welche günstigen reisen
und kommt irgendwo günstig unter so das
funktioniert ganz gut
was genau studiert medien und marketing
management wie ich habe ein video gesagt
dass ich war da schon 100 jahre nicht
mehr
mach mal zwölf sekunden delay also eine
freundin nein ich schreibe mir alle alle
über 18 sind meine die ems mag sagt es
kann zu empfehlen also an sich ja
grundsätzlich schon aber ich würd ich
bin mit max oder bin wie max an der
privaten uni und das kann ich wieder das
ist nicht gut das würde ich nicht
empfehlen geht eine staatliche keine
ahnung das ist völliger quatsch viel zu
teuer
max ganz wird noch mal gucken ob der die
länder nach wie vor da ist bestimmt ne
max was dein lieblings harry potter
charakter ich habe tatsächlich noch nie
in harry potter filmen gesehen deswegen
kann ich das nicht beantworten
max tut sich sehr schwer
das ist so eine scheiße mit diesem audio
hier
so ich geh jetzt auf zehn sekunden delay
finde ich sehr verwundert es wert dass
ihr trotz der technisch technischen
technischen probleme alle noch zu
schaffen und sogar noch mehr werden
ich könnte mir das nicht angucken
wahrscheinlich aber nur zehn sekunden
verzögerung jetzt muss es aber
funktionieren ja neue release heute oder
morgen das best den zweiten teil der
besten video serie
viele grüße an jana ja sehr gut wenn an
einer privatschule turnhalle da wegen
schimmel schon ewigkeiten nicht benutzen
ja perfekt so fühle ich mich auch an
meiner uni ohne schimmel und so macht
deutlich besser guck mal
es ist immer
ok immer noch so ein sekündchen atom ist
immer noch ein bisschen schneller
ja na dann freunde
es wird es ist sehr gut dass wir jetzt
schon 20 minuten mit dem stream und
macht nichts für tattoos gemacht haben
deshalb kann es eigentlich nicht laufen
sehr gut natürlich wieder die ersten
ablenkungen hingegeben habe und so
wirklich gehört das produkt noch mal ein
bisschen freuen wenn das nicht synchron
im alter.de guckt uns an hallo
ja es tut mir leid
die hatte leider in den tag doppelt
geplant und ist jetzt bei einem anderen
kumpel drehen und ist deswegen nicht
dabei
was soll ich nicht verdient hängt
zwischendurch das ist sehr schlecht
warum das deutsch englisch fall zu sehen
man hängen sollte das lied eurer
internet connection und mit sicherheit
nicht an meiner ich bin ist meine und
max wo ist sebastian sebastian könnten
wir mal kurz anrufen nicht schade aber
vielleicht kommt noch coole andere leute
ich bin die coolste person die hier
heute live sehen werdet von daher
solltet euch mit dem zufrieden geben was
sie bekommen du sagst es greift nicht
immer zu den sternen ja wenn auch die
sonne und der mond hier sitzen kurz mein
ipad und dann kannst du ja ich kann
alles machen was sind die vegan meist
ganz mitbekommen wie ist das mit der
mutter hört ihr überhaupt was von der
musik ist das cool und ist es laut genug
oder zu leise musik spontan tattoos oder
geplante
januar nimmt alle haupt weiß ich gar
nicht ob das geht vielleicht machst du
einfach gucken weil die sonos an der
wird die musik ist perfekt die feier
computer sieg ist perfekt und sehr
entspannend geil da der nach genau so
wie es sein soll
germania twist effekt ist diana vegan
seit einer woche sehr gut ich habe auch
ein youtube projekt gedreht bin dafür
vegan geworden habe nicht geraucht nicht
getrunken nicht gekauft jeden tag sport
gemacht und habe ab dem dritten tag
nicht mehr gefilmt und deswegen werde
die das niemals zu gesicht bekommen um
euch mit allen bei videos ich glaube ich
habe so viele halbe videos die ich nie
einen film klar obwohl die ideen so cool
waren und jetzt zb einmal so etwas
gemacht so eine woche lang nur nelle
untypische outfits tragen
nach dem dritten tag hatte ich keine
lust mehr keine fotos machen sie können
keine fixe erbarmen hört einfach
irgendwann man sich doch man muss das
nicht durchziehen man muss durch genauso
wie mit diesem filial inc video was ich
gemacht habe
jetzt haben echt unerwartet viele leute
da drauf geklickt und sachen darüber
gekauft wie viel geld ich das
zusammengekommen aber das soll ich das
mal gucken zwischenstand erst danach
nichts mehr
und danach dann gar nichts mehr dafür
gemacht was mega dumm ist weil das
eigentlich ganz gut funktioniert hat und
ich mache die kamera noch ein stückchen
höher dann seht ihr nämlich mehr vom
warum bist du ja total beschränkte
auswahl geflossen so dumm
ich stelle mir die frage als auch fragt
nicht warum
warum
dann solltet ihr ist auf einmal nicht
reingeschaut aber eine monetarisierung
ist bei mir kein thema von ich muss ich
mache kurz will weg ich habe jetzt
wahrscheinlich schon so ohne dass ich
mein equipment bezahlt habe so 500 euro
ein youtube gesteckt und quasi nichts
rausbekommen also wird auch hier das
video im o ja ich benutze halt auch
mutter auf die ich lust habe also so
copyright mit musik und so weil ich
darauf nicht verzichten will
also es liegt nicht daran dass ich
nichts verdienen könnte es liegt daran
dass ich nicht auf dinge verzichten will
die mir an dem genau und das ist sehr
schlecht
aber so ist das also als drei wochen
durch erhöhten im video verdienten sich
gebracht
kannst du bitte auf den link mal in der
regel beschreibung der ganzen gemacht er
ist automatisch könne und es um zu
verhindern was ein video das vom mail
ist perfekt sagte sie es ist auf dem
kopf stehend das war cool neues
lebensmotto er perfekt karim hat irgend
jemand geschrieben
spontane tattoos oder geplante ich habe
acht oder neuen tattoos und davon war
keins geplant das liegt nicht daran dass
ich keine lust auf und geplant das hätte
sondern eher daran dass ich sieben davon
selber gestochen habe und die maschine
in die hand genommen habe bevor ich mir
gedanken gemacht habe so nach dem motto
das war nicht weil ich nicht wollte
der tätowierer erzkörper dem mann
geschrieben dass so eine biersorte bei
unseres der heimat das können wäre
tatsächlich sehr witzig aber das möchte
nicht mein leben lang auf der haut
tragen wissen weißt du das motiv schon
ein kannst du jetzt bitte in unseren
goldene mitte kommen
eigentlich nein ja genau was im leben
kommt marco nowak uhr morgens und die so
wie normale menschen wie ich 18 18
also ich war dieses semester einmal in
der uni hat sich eigentlich lieber bin
und deshalb seid besser auf streber dann
seid ihr nicht wie lang geht der film
gehört
angefangen habe du hast ein semester
wenigen hat sich und tschüss
hallo hallo aschaffenburg gang
wir waren mal einen abend in einer
schaffen burg das habt ihr vielleicht
auch in dem rückblick video gesehen das
war ein bisschen unkontrolliert muss ich
ehrlich sagen das war ein bisschen
alkohol ich ja was studierst du design
also machst du alles so müsste
wahrscheinlich bei jana vorbeischauen
es geht ja abhängig nehmen wir so wir
nehmen skateboard dave king skateboard
coli
vielen dank an georgi lässt weil ich
dabei die hat uns aber ihre to machine
gegeben und ich bau dir jetzt erst mal
zusammen und gucke dass wir das alles
hinbekommen
tut mir leid hätte jetzt erstmal keinen
kriegsdienst habe aber egal ich mache
das mache ich werde hier eine runde was
geht auch freunde wo steht denn ich habe
noch nie auf youtube gesehen oder das
gesehen oder so
deshalb musste ich ihn hier wie viele
leute da zuschauer 450 leute was geht ab
450 leute ja ich wusste einfach mal
sagen dass seine krass inspiration für
mich bist dann zwei dann greift er also
alles oh mein gott die kette wir dir
einfach ein einfaches dave was sagst du
dazu
schwierig schwierig aber der sport ist
geweckt wir werden gefragt hattet ihr
mal gefühle zwischen euch ja wir haben
immer noch sehr viele menschen irgendwo
max ist zwischen uns und städte wie ein
meerschweinchen auch eine gute idee aber
ihr müsst wissen ich bin freund von so
super geraden linien und so einfachen
motiven mit nicht so schattierungen
unseren meerschweinchen mit schmiere ich
glaube ich in dieser hinsicht
krankmacher schreibt leute ihr seid ja
bei mir auf der couch gut dass du zum
lernen weg gegangen ist denn jetzt
unseren streams schwöre ich wollten den
richtigen sein handy hatte nehmen besser
wäre es ja in diese spekulation so ich
rate mehr machen ja einfach ist
verträumt auch als tatsächlich das
stimmt aber ich habe gesehen was zu mehr
film wird black gegeben hast das ist
erst mal gemacht habt echt ist dass ich
so was war nicht so gemeint es tut mir
leid
hallo freunde der leichten ist übrigens
um inhalte mehr hast du wer so ekelhaft
ich hast du das auch aber ich würde zwar
gerne machen es gibt einen mega witziges
video von max bei auch mal was kanal wo
er ist mehr gemacht und irgendwann hatte
er keine lust mehr hat einfach
angefangen die leute sucht zu beleidigen
da kommt ein video hallo
soweit wir hier mit diesem wert
schneidig weit schafft und wenn wir
glück haben noch heute
was würdest du sagen so die späteste
uhrzeit wo man noch holt tragen kann
21 30
leute die bisschen älter sind ich hoffe
bis 130 schaffe ich das leute machen big
tree style die immer aber ich werde
natürlich schon gut wenn wir den
instanzen aber hast du dann irgendwas
somit wir den aussetzen könnten was denn
so malt man das quasi da drauf und dann
prägt das durch und dann aus ihnen das
ausleihen und dann mussten
[Musik]
so wollte ich jetzt hier erstmals ein
bisschen rum
obwohl das schreibt laufen ich so marte
der gute dave läuft sein wir das
eigentlich gar nichts trinken wenn ich
dich jetzt trainiere das eigentlich gar
nicht geben sonst stunden vorher nur
noch du darfst die letzten zwei wochen
darf nichts getrunken haben eigentlich
nicht ja also keine ahnung
es tut mir so leider nicht das tut mir
wirklich wirklich leid an alle die hier
wenn irgend jemand ist oder zuschauer
tätowierer ist ich möchte nicht dass
respekt was ihr macht aber ich möchte es
trotzdem einfach mache weil ich dann
lust drauf bist du raus einfach selber
machen genau das tue ich das gesagt sein
ich weiß dass sich vernünftig zu
tätowieren sehr viel arbeit und sehr
viel lernen erfordert aber aber das kann
mir einem halben jahr dann bei mir auch
im studium machen
genau weil das als dass leute von euch
noch nicht wussten ich mache gerade ist
das wirklich eine kette via ausbildung
es gibt ja keine gesetzliche staatlich
anerkannte ausbildung aber auch lernen
dass gerade in einem studio und deshalb
muss natürlich auch sagen dass zumindest
da natürlich alles ganz anders abläuft
und man sich hier an auf jeden fall kein
beispiel nehmen sollte aber wir machen
es trotzdem weil wir das drauf haben und
wäre dumm sind
ich mach mal
ich muss jetzt auch wieder cool aussehen
aber apropos ich kann meinen da ist zu
zeigen
das muss immer ein creme zeigen
stimmt es gibt so viel zu zeigen sie
musik kann ich habe das noch gar nicht
gezeigt glaube ich habe meine story post
hier ist mein neues handy kamera und
davon
ich muss ich muss das fokussiert ich
kann einfach nicht lassen
puh
selber gemacht dass die arbeit nicht
gestochen von morgen wieder jeweils der
rechte arm ist
[Musik]
sind es sieht sehr cool sind es auch
sehr cool
so
[Musik]
bradley cooper und kult funktion als ja
ich will gut tragen wenn wir alle in
freiburg wollen sagt mir meine freunde
ich werde es auch hier fertig mit
eincremen
ich glaube ich habe alle bereiche
eingecremt
wenn nicht dann halt nicht ich wünsche
dir maschinen das waren brasil gericht
hast du auch einen richtigen rasierer
also in kleinen einmal rasierer nelecom
noch mal klamotten von dir ja ich bin
auf jeden fall dabei eigentlich nur
marke aufzuziehen
aber mir fällt kein name ein für marke
und das ziemlich wichtig diese prinz
tour sagen wir da überhaupt dran kommen
so ist schon dick verzögert
niemand hat gefragt über london bus
getroffen ist dass davon wer z
ich war backstage bei den auf der tour
und sie waren einmal mit mir feiern
können welches mit einer fahne believe
jemand fragt wo ich bin ich bin 17 buch
wie viel 17 ich bin sogar mittlerweile
größer als max kennen gelernt haben wir
machen ja nur babys wachsen doch
plötzlich so position getauscht weiß es
gar nicht weil du den stream abdecken
wollte
muss man comedy anrufen ich habe keine
ahnung wie es das kabel hier rein machen
ich probiere in der zeit aber natürlich
weiterhin fragen zu beantworten
das machen und dann verschrauben die
folie für das gerade rein machen
hast du eine folie ja so eine tüte war
sie für das kabel nicht stimmt ja ja das
ist beim nächsten mal okay ja das ist ja
eigentlich ein klammer und das dann
darin oder soll dann auch noch irgendwie
da so durch
ich warte erstmal aber das kann es ja
nicht aber ich wollte es ja schon nur
laufen lassen um zu gucken
ich habe wie gesagt keine ahnung von
solcher menschen von solcher maschinen
natürlich klar wie claude würde es nicht
funktionieren
dave erklärt keine ahnung ich muss sagen
dass ich desto öfter ich das gemacht
habe weiß ich hab das jetzt bis zu 56
mal gemacht oder so desto weniger habe
ich das gefühl ich bin sehr daran
abgelichtet nicht mehr irgendwelche
themen zu besprechen die mich wirklich
interessiert haben sowie das farbthema
oder das obdachlosen thema oder so und
sondern habe im endeffekt halt so stani
videos gemacht also fünf dinge die
keiner weiß das war echt habe mich nicht
so gefühlt
toni
alpha stein vielleicht hat ja aber nicht
jetzt
dass toni hier alle schramm toni tun
hallo tony tony hey das ist so ich habe
keine ahnung wie das funktioniert muss
kunst sowie anrufen
okay ich mache mein handy dann kann ich
auch wieder reden und bin nicht mehr
abgelenkt unterhalb ich muss kurz
unterhalten
hey freunde was kann ich ja gar nicht ob
ich die ganze zeit auf dem laptop die
kamera steht ja hier hey leute ich habe
in die maschine nach unten kommt und man
muss das unter wird dinge nicht
abschneiden beim abschrauben gemacht
magst du auch farbige tattoos oder nur
schwarz also ich persönlich nur schwarz
aber kommt halt auch immer auf die
person an also bei manchen leuten sieht
das auch geil aus wenn man farbig tattoo
geht es allerdings habe ich gehört dass
es in deutschland keine richtlinien gibt
es für die bestandteile von farbiger
tätowierfarben das heißt im prinzip
müsste ich mit was ihr da tätowiert
werden wenn ihr mit farbe tätowiert
werdet halt und schwarzer farbe gibt es
das scheinbar irgendwelche also bei
schwarz und weiß gibt es das scheinbar
immer welche maßnahmen habe ich aber
auch nur gehört also ich hab es nicht
selber recherchiert deshalb wenn es
nicht stimmt mit er hätte mich nicht
zeig mir deine tattoos dann müsste mich
aussehen sei keine lust drauf ich habe
hier allen hier als gutschein groß ist
ein kleines das hier da 1 und hier als
glaube ich ja das ist ja alles sein
hast du ein tattoo die fragen sind habe
ich seit ich war so sind vielleicht
sieht man dokumentiert hoch juliana
gerade eben schon schuldig schreibt
anzeige tattoo nackt und toni
ich habe mich schon mal für toni
ausgezogen wollte halloween party ja
weil die alle an den beinen sind und
dann habe ich viele leute die ich kannte
und dann habe ich einfach meine hose
unterwegs sein
ich bin mal drei mal ist auch da hallo
wo kann bremen um zu unterhalten
die wurst sein logo ich habe dir mal an
ich rufe jetzt marco nowak von westen
her und meine tasche von benjamins sie
drückt aufs gas die wir wissen ja wieder
zurück ins normale leben das sind
ökologisch ich hasse das lernen das
bereitet mich unsere morgen dann einig
trotz armen hat so kurzer zeit versucht
das kabel auf der falschen seite die
andere heimlich und bleibst du nur
kannst ja man ja schnell wir fangen
gleich an und wir brauchen mehr
unterhaltung
der ganztag der capri kommt auch max wo
hast du deine events absolut oder sind
eine last ab es ist sehr geheime
amsterdam
ja ich habe dem secondhand kaufst du mir
sehr leid dass sie denn auch kaufen
können und natürlich nicht mal ein
bisschen raus stellen weil wir sehen aus
wie die kassen
ich bin noch weit höher
als er als feindlich ich glaube kinder
wird nur noch mehr aber ich meine das
war der deal ich kann das alles angucken
richtig aus also ich kann das auch nicht
hinkommt hatte jetzt müssten sich das
ändern ja noch den rat gegeben habe
diana die augen zukneifen werden wir die
lampen unverstellter es ist ja lustig so
ja meist mit 550 aktive wie lange seid
ihr live das ist mir nicht fokus ist
falsch sorry mache ich alles macht er
anders
janna woher hast du deine handy kappe
das ist manchmal wie könnt ihr alle so
hübsch sein naja es ist nicht so einfach
hast du nicht was wir uns lieber den
bucks 6 es ist ein bisschen das ist ein
zusammen ein zusammenspiel der feinsten
gene aus ganz deutschland
neben muss den stempel machen ja die
quali ist ja viel zu gut als drucker
drücker die quali ist echt richtig gut
ja ich habe natürlich in fünf minuten
und jetzt glaube ich geht dahin hätte
lieber ein bisschen kleiner was das was
immer du was cool aussieht alle alle
außer max waren mit hübsch und alter
michael das aussieht really cool dave
zeig mir deine tattoos okay ich glaube
so wie viel sparen heute sprechen 1000
mag spricht tatsächlich ein paar mehr
als wir und da rainha die talente sprich
album englisch deutsch können wir alle
und dave kein bisschen französisch
italienisch japanisch
doch davon
das sind die die ich selber gemacht und
die die ich bekommen habe oder die mir
gemacht wurden die sind auf den armen
zeigt mir das was du mit dem mit den
kasten
ich habe halt kein kein ding gehabt um
die sachen auszufüllen deswegen sie die
nicht aus
die bildqualität ist besser als ich in
wirklichkeit sehen können sich freunde
ich hab sie ist sehr gut lang und breit
daran gearbeitet dass das hier so gut
funktioniert was studiert ihr gefühlt
gar nicht
du bist so ein bisschen an rand und ich
bin ein bisschen weit drin hast du mal
besser hierhin die schritte ein bisschen
ein bisschen gehe ich aus ja ne yo hat
das mister tom in meiner hand
ich habe vorhin meinen schwanz gewinnt
nicht millionär gemacht schreibt bitte
setzen die vasco mein gott das war also
hier darauf musste malen und dann
drückst du das durch auf diese folie auf
welche das heißt manchmal hier mal
gucken ob das dadurch gehen einfach
ausdrucken weil dann fährst du auch
nicht mehr kannst du speichern
ja das ist okay so das geil und könnte
so bestimmten duplizieren und dann hier
rüber
juli ist es din a4 größe ok druck mal
einfach so und dann schauen wir so ich
endlich mal wieder dass ich ein bisschen
was erzähle wenn ihr ein bisschen was
schreibt dann kommt jakob auch noch ja
da kommt aber der hund nicht und wenn
nein besser ist es immer und jetzt wenn
er einmal was hier los ist dann wird die
kritik immer was los ist dann stellt
sich auch immer
ja das stimmt ja aber jetzt bin ich ja
mal hier steht auf heck ist er schon
längst gemacht und konnte das nächste
mal nach berlin max waren mindestens
schon monaten nicht mehr will muss ich
dann kommt man mit mir
am fünften bin ich in berlin fünfter auf
6 ist donnerstag auf weiter da nur einen
abend ich bin auf der anitas
weihnachtsfeier sechster feiert der
insight wieder da vielleicht weil man
überlegt weil ich habe am vierten termin
in würzburg bitte dahin könnt ihr mit
eurer rapper namen sagen max hat gute
momentaufnahme
verschiedenste meiner ist peru ich da
david martin war tino ihn das ruhig so
reden wie anton bezler dann gibt es
natürlich big groß farina erfindungen
sind aus deutscher und 3 und coconut ist
mein am übernahme mein name ist süß wie
raphael outfit picobello tracken
lipgloss
da wurde schon weiter geschrieben das
habe ich am wochenende beim frühstück
mit meiner mama gesagt wenn du solltest
mal nach mainz dann rasten die alle aus
soll ist aber das war jetzt nichts was
ich mir gerade spontan ausgedachten
etwas länger kuhlmann sind sich vollmann
sieht vor dass ich habe zuvor die
glänzende haut altert aber auch weil das
licht in die fresse ja ich würde
vielleicht ein bisschen indirekt machen
gegen gegen die wand besteht öfter im
stream auf als ich am ganzen tag ja gut
er kann wie braun ich bin gegen diese ja
ich weiß dass ich weiß bin so was mal
okay du hast das jetzt weggelassen
ich finde es eigentlich geiler so dass
für meine ersten block gene
deshalb bin ich jetzt sieht man unsere
fähigkeit unterschied auch nicht mehr so
doll
siehst du nicht schon wieder braun warum
ist nach würzburg ich wohne oder us
würzburg nicht auch dabei seien ja was
hast du dann termin das so von wegen sie
verstehen und zurück an einem tag
cool dann komme ich aber wahrscheinlich
echt ist jan er erschaffen wo ja und das
ist ja eine bewusste zahlen oder nicht
hier ist wird
[Musik]
brüssel beim 1 du bist du rüsselsheim
das dumme ist
die insel ist der look der erstes jakob
dokumente der fed gleich erst los ist da
nicht so schnell vor ort drei stunden 43
fährt man mit dem auto fährt man leben
alter ich bin dafür telekom die kampagne
hast du dich wieder zu hören ja ich
mache mir auch ich musste ja da kommt
jetzt wollen ist ein gutes stück
entfernt der größte zwei gründe ganz gut
ich wette wenn jakob reinkommt macht er
so versteckt sein gesicht hinter seinen
händen ich fahr wette 50 euro
ok ich kann es mir nicht leisten aber
ich werde nicht leicht aber ich muss
dieses 16.000 aber meine krankenkasse
zahlen weil wir wurden letzthin letzte
woche 7500 abgebucht aber ich bin eben
krankenkasse an alle christen bin
natürlich ein kleiner tricks und bekommt
deswegen mein geld wieder ich krieg mal
geld aus wieder
ja wenn ich nicht mal darum kümmere
kommst du bitte mal rein
nicht dass hier auf dem braun hatte komm
mal reinsetzen sowie das ist die ganze
zeit hier selbst sich
mein bruder hatte eben und ich wollte
kommentieren aber ich war nur mit
extended notenschnitt deswegen konnte
ich ja ich habe das habe meine fünfte
version erwartet dass du so was wenn du
weit kommst
ich habe sogar mal was geht hier ab
alles konzentriert welchem land sonntags
würde ich das hier
sie müssen wir die ende endlich wird es
mir hier brauchen perfekte größe
nadal ich würde es mich so also bis auf
die ausrichtung was hier passiert war
bruder 700 zuschauer das ist sehr
schlecht aber das ist mit diesem stift
nicht so gut wie hallo das ist die
größte die wir brauchen
okay aber soll ich das jetzt noch mal
neu ausdrucken weil dann kannst du es
besser ab tauschen und dann schneiden
wir dass daraus kann dass er mit dieser
film da wieder dran festgeschrieben ja
kannst du ich hol mir mal ne aufdrucken
viel einfacher
na gut er auf einen großen schluck
aber wenn ich jetzt gebastelt ok warum
ist maxi da da weil der nach wie vor
nicht geschafft hat mit jakob arjouni zu
geben was sie eigentlich hätten tun
sollen 50 euro weniger jahren das stimmt
das hat kann warum essen wir das nicht
du kannst es gerne essen aber ich bin
mir sicher das ist erst richtig
entertaining wird sobald die beiden in
der uni sind weil dann haben die genug
zeit witzige kommentare zu schreiben
ich war ja komm bald wieder rtl auch
freunde rtl ist ein gutes stichwort ich
habe video geplant wenn das funktioniert
halleluja dann ist holland in not
holland in not ja das ganze land ja wenn
es so ist so ein sprichwort
so kann ich halte von roland weg waren
die worte fangruppen kann es niemals
sehen der klausur waren obwohl selber
fragen aus der klausur vor der klausur
junge was ist allerdings zehn und 13
das ist schon der uni wünschen auch
möchten welche gesetz aus schlüssel gibt
es bei der firma diskussionen diese
formulierung hat kein ergebnis weil
google selbst aus schürze ist hängig wie
sein design
aber so funktioniert das nicht ich muss
sie richtig arbeiten können wir müssen
jetzt los mit rein mussten von einem
sinnlos getötet
muss ja ich wollte hier erstmal gucken
ja ja ja ich hab ich den augen von der
leyen die man nicht sagen darf davon
sagen nein davon
ich wünsche aber was hat kohl jacke aber
werde ich keine tore also wer pipinsried
ostseite vbg haben will bei jakob
einschleimen euro ja warum konntest du
mich nicht mal öfter alter ist hänge auf
jedem bild wenn man ist zu auch noch
vorne aber dann bringt
dabei bin ich halt die coolste viel spaß
beim kacken dave dave ließ das beim
kacken nello willst du mich tätowieren
hab noch zwölf euro ja ich hätte wieder
in einem halben jahr vielleicht mal das
hat ja kommt für einen rolli an fragt
mich nicht keiner welche er wollte nicht
wirklich finden müsst ihr das ist das
hinscheiden also ich glaube das ganze
denn es ist dazu bekommen ich hab
gestern noch zu deiner mutter gesagt das
ist nicht tätowieren würde wir haben
halt
wie gesagt das gemacht der junge wollte
er auch sagen kann dann kommt noch
kundtun
wir gehen jetzt war das nicht hätte wir
ist das sofa ja du sagst es deswegen
aber wie verrückt kommt ihr das
thumbnail an jakob und trotzdem 700
zuschauer
also wenn ich das mal sehen würde würde
ich eine sache nicht machen und das da
brauche ich würde also sagen machen
brauchen sie es drauf
ich würde eine sache die muss man ihm
ein arbeitsplatz in einem sonst noch
nicht auf sicher und das muss eher
steril bleiben hier alles deswegen ist
ungünstig dass jetzt die miss atom
packungen darauf lag ja ja ja ich muss
[Musik]
du kannst ja den nutzer einfach weiter
aber völlig verrückt wie lange das sofa
gehalt machen will
[Musik]
ich muss ganz ehrlich wenn du nicht
willst dann schauen sie mal bei uns
jetzt wirklich einstieg angucken kann
man versteht dass lost warum ist das was
würdest du ja warum ist das so verspätet
also bald which is ist er durch
annähernd zu verstärken
dort montiert ich habe das aber so
eigentlich wenn irgendwas schlimmes
passiert war schnell ein machen kann und
wenn ich auf niedrigstem latenz habe
dann kann man nicht zurückspulen und
wenn die leute sich mehrmals ein
liebliches gesicht anschauen wo er schon
zwischen den chat dass sie hier bleiben
sollte einzelnen chat wenn die hier
bleiben sollen freunde du kannst jetzt
ja das ist eben viel zulässt wollen wir
das nicht einfach da draufkleben
verlieren was wir jetzt durch so eine
partei schon dann kleben was da drauf
und dann ist das lesen dann stelle ich
vielleicht alter ich hab so was hätte
stellt die kamera darauf ein dass man
sieht was du machst und dann noch die
webcam dass man trotzdem musste das
leben erst an new york der zuschauer
sich gut hundert mal du sagst es jakob
du sagst ist 700 ha ha ha ha wachstum
für den text entschieden
freunde wofür mache ich eigentlich noch
videos 700 zuschauer das ist ja fast so
viel wie ich krieg das video das habe
ich mache jetzt können wir mal ganz kurz
sagen was ihr von der idee halten
ich guck dir ganz dünnen bild ja ich
auch diese kamera ihr könnt mir mal
sagen was ihr davon haltet ich möchte
jeden advent einmal stream mit marx jana
kerle jakob marko
bestimmt zurück bastian show die ganz
genau genau sagen was sie davon hält
wird genau rihanna penner
ich will mir nicht meine mutter gib mir
nicht meine worte erst mal aber das ist
nicht viel besser da sehen wir einer
show leider immer noch mach das weg gebe
ja auch andere welt war wie oft wir
kriegen hat wenn du einmal die nummer 1
nein nein das wird nicht ins so jeden
advent einmal als ihm einmal
plätzchenbacken einmal glühwein machen
und laufen bis zur besinnungslosigkeit
das letzte mal als jakobs alkohol hat
ist seine nase gebrochen ich bin lieb
warum
und er hat schon angefangen gesagt es
ist der jüngste von euch ich natürlich
die anderen bus gänsehaut geben soll
da bist du schon mal relativ früh
abgehauen weil
ich höre ich bin noch nie von dem
musterabkommen weil ich gut gesorgt
nach ohne lüge ich wäre ja dann
irgendwann co kg schnell dass die wörter
wenn das im februar ist fünf minuten von
mir das kannst du vergessen dass sie da
hinlaufen okay jetzt kann nicht ist es
jetzt die festkleben ein navy muss noch
festlegen aber ich hab's abgemacht wie
alt ich bin
20 alle anderen sind ich bin 21 wir sind
die beiden babys genau ich bin 20 jahre
sei aber hastig genauer jacobs 21 und 22
europa ist ihr seid schon so zeigen dass
es sich gar nicht mehr nur zugehört
ruft mich einfach über facetime
ich glaube wir lassen max um jakob
einfach über facetime anrufen und dann
blende ich das hier schon ein
die macht der großen projekte halten ja
aber so wie canon oder so denn es ist
mein laden ja ist es nämlich wird mit
schätze brauchen den wagen
habt ihr viele blender also ich würde
gern ich habe bis dato die meisten
tattoos an stellen die man nicht mein
leben bis zum sommer 220 würde ich gerne
ein paar mehr stellen voll machen die
man immer so sieht aber ruft über
facetime andere blende ich ja perfekt
dann bekommt ihr liegt aus der uni kiel
am ehesten todes verschoben wie denn was
ich muss kurz selber gucken freundin
geschrieben noch scream muss kurz fresse
halten
ich kann mich gar nicht sogar schon vor
weißer belag schlimmsten noch können wir
zu gesprächen bereit
das kurz ich muss also sorry freunde das
ist ein bisschen lost gegenüber heute
muss man viel spaß gut jakob wie
vorbereitet die uni gehst und rucksack
und alles immer na ja aber das wirklich
lustig oder dieses semester nicht einmal
inne
und trotzdem schaffst du außerhalb der
uni noch mehr als ich das ist mehr eine
peinlichkeit geht
ich mache diverse andere dinge nicht
wahr
zum beispiel jeden tag mit max zu
stützen seit einigen jahren jeden tag
mit marx mittagessen zeit ein tag mit
max abendessen seit einem jahr hin was
verliebt seid seit einem jahr ja was
soll ich sagen es war wirklich die beste
entscheidung von max sich von jana zu
trennen weil seitdem ich habe max genau
an der falschen gelernt mich was ich hab
ja oder oder es war mein land meine gute
entscheidung beste entscheidung von jana
weil dadurch konnte ich mag es komplett
für mich alleine haben um seitdem ich
muss am tisch und sich das sehr stark
aus du kannst es gerne machen wir genau
du kannst du ein bisschen fester drücken
und du kannst auch irgendwie
kugelschreiber nehmen oder so es geht
darum dass es mit ein bisschen druck
macht und wenn du diese blaue folie
hochhebt dann muss das durchdrücken auf
diese seite darunter sehr gut ich habe
das letzte mal ein kugelschreiber
gemacht das ging sehr gut
wieso gehst du nicht in die uni hallo
ja wir also ich studiere nicht mit jakob
und jakob und max zusammen ich studiert
zwar dasselbe aber bin zwei semester
unter denen also ich bin im dritten
semester diesem fünften deswegen habe
ich grundsätzlich nicht uni wenn die uni
haben aber das würde ich keinen
unterschied machen ich mag was geht kurs
schicken wir mal ein paar beats dann
kann ich die im hintergrund laufen
lassen muss nicht irgendwelche copyright
free playlist hier laufen lassen ist der
ton eigentlich wieder besser geworden
und ich muss kunst checken ist okay oder
perfekt
ja freunde es ist sehr fein ja es sind
fünf minuten bestimmt fertig mit dem
stencils und dann können wir anfangen zu
tätowieren
es ist sehr am anfang hat es mir sehr
unbehagen bereitet hier so live in die
kamera zu reden weil ich schiss hatte
dass irgendwas ungeplant nicht
funktioniert oder irgendwas ungeplant
des domes passiert aber mittlerweile
fühle ich mich ziemlich confident
irgendwie und das macht spaß und es ist
mega meist dass so viele leute da sind
weil damit hätte ich nicht gerechnet
das sehr cool hintergrundmusik ist weg
es tut mir leid ich werde mich sofort
darum kümmern
sie sollte jetzt wieder da sein
ich bin in siegen geboren habe da gelebt
bis ich fertig war mit der schule bin
dann nach berlin gegangen habe da einen
job angefangen habe den in einem halben
jahr wieder gekündigt und bin nach köln
gezogen weil ich hier so ein paar leute
kennengelernt habe und youtube mäßig ist
man hier halt im himmel
ich tätowiere mich oder ja natürlich
aber ich bekomme auf jeden fall das ist
bist du oft in max wohnungen ohne dass
er da ist ja tatsächlich mittlerweile
ich habe zwar keinen schlüssel für die
wohnung was aber besser ist aber ich
würde sagen ich bin ja jeden tag von
morgens bis abends hier und wenn max
irgendwas zu erledigen hat wo ich nicht
dabei sein muss oder allgemein also
einfach nicht dabei bin dann bleibe ich
trotzdem hier in der wohnung also immer
wenn max irgendwas macht wo ich nicht
dabei bin bin ich die in wohnungen
eigentlich
ich bin mit
18 ausgezogen das ding ist
ich bin direkt nach der schule auf
reisen gegangen für ein paar monate nach
asien und von da aus dann also ich bin
nach der reise nie wieder zuhause
eingezogen von da aus dann nach berlin
und lüge ich bin nach berlin gegangen
nach der schule dann reisen und dann
nach köln
also mit 18 ausgezogen was auch oder mit
aber mit 18 ausgezogen ja aber das echt
gut also ja mal kommt aus der nähe von
köln siegen ist auch nur eine stunde weg
so dass echte sie deswegen ist köln das
einer der gründe warum warum ich mich so
wohl fühle in köln dass ich weg von zu
hause bin aber trotzdem wenn ich lust
habe die sich schnell nach hause
ich habe mir neulich das auto von max
ausgeliehen und bin für ein also ich bin
um 21 uhr losgefahren
nach siegen bei einem kumpel auf den
geburtstag gegangen und irgendwie um 81
hab da nichts getrunken und so bindungen
1 uhr nachts wieder zurück und das war
super easy das halt bisschen
problematisch wenn man in berlin ist
oder so man fängt er an zu tätowieren
jana da ja nur stress das war nur eine
frage da vorne sitzt jana und die macht
gerade instanzen fertig und dann geht's
gleich rund
so dumm ist es egal
ja ich hab's gemacht
hannover guckst du den stream
[Musik]
dann guckt auch nicht reicht dann ruft
dich später wieder an okay weil ich bin
gerade live kukksi wirklich bitte nicht
an
du wirst es nicht mögen du wirst es
nicht mögen guckst du nicht an days auf
youtube tja mein vater findet das findet
ziemlich viel gut und witzig und so was
ich mache wenn es aber so um tattoos
geht und sich vor allem selber
tätowieren dann ist er absolut kein
freund davon aber es war dumm
die info jetzt zu geben weil wie
finanziert du dir dein live ich arbeite
so mit max und sebastian und macht fotos
und videos und so macht das alters hat
besser funktioniert als jeder stenzel
den hier gemacht habe
so freundlich fest haben die jungs mal
an ja das wäre das beste vermutlich wie
völlig seine schullaufbahn so ziemliche
straighte also ich habe einmal schule
gewechselt kurz vor der oberstufe weil
ich auf eine schule gegangen bin wo man
jedes jahr auf ski freizeit fahren kann
ich habe sehr sehr wenig zeit in die
schule investiert das hat aber trotzdem
funktioniert also ich hatte super viele
gerade in den letzten zwei jahren eine
schule super viele unentschuldigte
fehlstunden aber weil mir der kopf
einfach nach nach anderen dingen stand
und ich das gefühl hatte meine zeit
super zu verschwenden
das ist nicht ratsam also macht das am
besten nicht aber bei mir hat super
funktioniert und dann war das okay so
aber es besser wenn er vernünftig in die
schule wird und das macht
ich hatte die tattoos gerade eben schon
gezeigt ich zeig dir gleich einfach noch
mal wenn ich das neue habe dann zeige
ich alle anderen ich guck gar keine
serien lieblingsserie auf oldtimer sind
schutz und piggy bleiben das sind auch
die einzigen die ich jemals geguckt habe
die pläne diesem winter ja ich habe den
geilsten plan für die videos und streams
das wird mir ganz also vom zwanzigster
dezember an bis zu 28 könnt ihr euch
darauf einstellen dass videos und
streams vom skifahren kommen
das zumindest jetzt gerade der plan ich
hatte einen abischnitt von 22 oder 23
glaube ich
ich fasse board und ski ich habe muss so
langsam mal wieder ein bisschen weg
kommen davon nur fragen zu beantworten
glaubt mir die zeit kann man ja mal
zeigen was ich für eine tour jetzt
geplant hat jan hat es nämlich schon
auch gemalt
und das hier
so sieht es aus
was mit marko
ich bin mir jetzt mal die jungs am zu
facetime und guckt ob ich das hier
geregelt bekomme stream wird glaube ich
hochgeladen aber ich werde eher so ein
highlight clips davon machen oder so
aber ich glaube ich lass das jetzt lasst
den stream jetzt erstmal für zwei tage
oder so online und dann schauen wir mehr
glück oder mehr können beim foto und
video verlauf ist schwierig zu sagen ich
glaube also nicht so der freund von
dinge auf glück schieben
ich hab glück in dem sinne gehabt dass
ich irgendwann leute kennengelernt habe
die die arbeit zu schätzen wussten oder
zu schätzen wussten dass ich das so
gemacht habe wie ich das gemacht habe
und dass ich hungrig war mehr sachen zu
machen und viel zu machen ja glück glück
wahrscheinlich dass ich leute
kennengelernt habe die bereit waren mich
dabei zu unterstützen aber ansonsten man
wird nicht gebucht weil man glück hat
sondern man wird gebucht weil leute das
cool finden was man macht das aber bei
allem so thon ist wieder asynchron
freunde der ton verschiebt sich immer
weiter ich probiere das jetzt noch
einmal zu regeln und dann tätowieren mir
aber schon und jetzt kommt mein vater
mit sicherheit schon das tut mir sehr
leid papa
ok ton ist asynchronen aber ich lasse es
jetzt einfach so ich habe keine lust das
zu machen
tut mir leid vor hoffentlich regelt sich
das über die zeit
okay das ist wirklich hier noch auf dem
sofa
ich habe sogar mal bei mir ich bin
wirklich der zweitreichste mensch der
welt ich seit meiner schwester am
wochenende die haare gefärbt und musste
in der zwischenzeit also in der zeit wo
ich die farbe auf ihre haare gemacht
habe fünf mal mein boden mit
nagellackentferner reinigen weil das die
ganze darunter getropft ist und dann
immer so also immer so knapp neben den
teppich und direkt bei der boden blau
also so direkt nicht weggewischt aber
der boden gefährt deshalb als ich bin
sehr toll patrick ich übernehme kennt
verantwortete dieses sofa will ich nur
sagen games live und camper hier hat er
seine freundin von uns das sofa dreckig
gemacht als allererste deswegen habe
mich vor dass hier weiter fertig zu
machen aber wir kriegen das schon
hinkriegen bisschen wir können erst mal
gucken wie wir das du zuerst war ich
handschuhe und desinfektionsmittel
[Musik]
focus ist auch wieder auf den micro der
fokus ist wieder auf dem micro schreiben
die leute anstrengend das aktions mittel
auch für die haut ich glaube ich mache
das dahin einfach der einfachheit halber
[Musik]
hier ist überwiegend nicht reduziert
kann ich dann immer noch weiter im chat
lesen und irgendwelche sachen
beantworten und wohlig jetzt micro ein
bisschen weiter an meinen mund und dann
hört man auch die tormaschine nicht so
laut dass
mal
[Musik]
das fenster in den stichen drauf max ist
sohn dort verdammter ihren mann benutzte
ich einfach seine wohnung mittlerweile
schon so standardmäßig irgendwelche
sachen wichtig was gesagt hat dass wir
so die vaseline und die sachen dass wir
da nicht mit dem finger rein gehen die
holz bekommen wieder besucht wir sind
nicht lange allein geblieben freunde zur
ausnahme
ja ohne witz jetzt kommt die ganze zeit
dieselben fragen
ich könnte mir ja noch so gut als titel
vor vorstellen bin ich ja auch bald
könnte mir das hier 24 713 sehr gut da
brauchen wir gar kein schlechtes
gewissen zu haben dass wir so langsam
doch nichts gemacht habe
aber wir haben gut gut gelagert was
sollte ich mir noch neues bier und von
anfang an eigentlich steht jetzt auf
meinem plan katholiken reinigen und
desinfizieren in diesem fall ja
natürlich
sie mussten natürlich nicht
du weißt du weißt du so jetzt für eine
abfrage her was wir waren wie
desinfizieren müssen ein bisschen lost
auch nicht doch ich kann mir sagen wie
wir das sonst immer gemacht haben also
erstmal jetzt erstmal meinen bei machen
absehbar wochen so du hast du schon
einmal sei sie dann noch ich habe da
schon quasi ihr leben mit ihm habe es
muss ganz komplett sein
erst wenn so ein haar eintätowiert wird
was wie ich das verstehe ich so sitze
ich jetzt folge kannst du dich in diesem
streamer weiterhin setzen damit ich
sehen kann
ich weiß nicht 15 sekunden oder so hast
du sie ein absichtlich eingestellt
[Musik]
dass die du kannst wenn du möchtest
immer kannst es auch auf dem handy noch
aufrufen
ich glaube es gut ich war einfach
großflächig die haare komplett weg habt
ihr habt ihr eben irgendetwas mit
einzelnen städten gesagt ja ja der ganze
kette ist ja dass ich gesagt 1 in den
tschad venjakob und max nicht im juni
gehen soll
jänner treibt meine taschen voller band
freunde wir haben
kölns nummer 1 newcomer repariert ich
sag's wie sie es wohl nicht es ist und
der technik
das half nichts mehr in dem moment mal
gegen den strich das ist das beste stark
die symrise drauf teilen sich platz eins
was kommt danach der sagt wenn ich sage
dass also vermeiden ich mag den preis
noch aus
da war es auch sehr gut tatsächlich also
gegen ist so ein bisschen geführt dass
oettinger unter den köln aber es ist
tatsächlich auch eines meiner lieblings
biere
dazu müssen wir das deutsche ski ziel
dachte ja natürlich sehr steril werden
einfach nicht hinten gut ich bin dick
rot färbt schon an standorten wo leben
die konzept vermeiden mein papa hat
bestimmt geschrieben wir sind zahlen
sind fleißig und lernen zeigt mal die
tormaschine tut hätte wären sehr doll
weg kommt auf die stelle an und kommt
auf den tätowierer an und auf die
maschine an und attackierte wir relativ
sticht also richtig dicht oder zu tief
schlecht wenn das natürlich überhaupt
nicht wie ich hoffe es tut nicht weh
weil ich hab auch keine erfahrung
also ist alles ohne gewehre gewehr hier
ich habe einmal erst jemanden tätowiert
perfekt und ich glaube ich hole mir noch
das
ein skateboard micro ein stück näher
[Musik]
das zum abwischen nachher wissen dass
benutzen wir so komplett zum hier das
desinfizieren
das hier ist um den stansell zu
übertragen ich erkläre das hier nicht
noch mal alles okay weil ich habe schon
war so ein video gemacht weil ich das
erklärt habe ihr sollt das eh nicht
anhand meiner erklärung machen weil ich
das nicht erklären kann also da so zeige
ich auch nicht so richtig
also du wie du bist du ja dessen bewusst
dass ich das nicht kann
ich bin mir dessen bewusst ja
tatsächlich
hey wurden
meine standard leute die meine videos
sonst immer kommentieren meine
gottverdammten ehrenmänner ja
tatsächlich soll ich das nur noch
schnell um stellt ja ist ja viel besser
dann sehen die leute auf uns ich mache
mich macht es so schnell so freunde
jetzt kommt hier habe ich das vernünftig
vorbereitet oder nicht nein natürlich
nicht
ein moment es dauert eine sekunde
freunde
ok nein nein nein
aha jetzt in die kamera
diese dort ja weil das nach dem essen
und der gleichheit
ich darf jetzt nur nicht mehr auf drei
seiten passt doch perfekt nicht wahr was
wollt ihr groß sehen und was klein unser
gesicht groß und das tätowieren klein
oder andersrum
das müsst ihr mir kurz sagen
so wie es ist besser ein doppeltop ist
besser der ton rufst du uns in groß
klein noch den trumpf
da ich komme hier überhaupt nicht klar
ist der ton ist rau synchron warte ich
muss selber checken
ich kann mich das kann mich nicht auf
vertrauen und so reinschreiben das alles
schief ist unsere freunde tut mir leid
das bisschen asynchron jetzt aber kann
ich nichts dran ändern oder nicht kann
ich nicht das hier ist jetzt das hier
ist vernünftig aber bilder nicht
synchron tones china ist nach außen
krone ein bisschen ton passt am besten
tun von tattoo ausmachen tones bester
ton ist schlimm
bild zu leise der ton ist gut ich kann
nichts dran ändern
zum leid tue mich die tage mit drei wie
zusammen und dann kann ich mir mal
erklären wie man das macht bild ist
jetzt komplett schwarz junge sich alter
nein nicht gut wenn man sie gar nichts
jetzt wird dann date wird dann hibbelig
ja natürlich will ich hier bin ich ja
aber du solche halt mich hier billig
werden
du bist doch dass das infizierte sorry
wann darf ich ein bisschen los
wie macht man das jetzt darauf
alle schütteln und wie manche es noch
drauf ich glaube da musst du nur die
obere kabbaj rum so ein bisschen was auf
die haut da ein bisschen was auf c war
und dann hallo hallo hallo alter ist
echt zu geisteskranken synchrones tut
mir leid die es nach wie vor dreckig ich
muss die wahrscheinlich streichen die
tage ein bisschen lost aber das wissen
ja irgendwann da du entscheidest du bist
renovieren
yaez schwieriges thema es gibt ein sehr
großes dilemma ich rauche schon richtig
lange richtig viel was richtig scheiße
ist so genau
einfach so dahin
ich glaube schon richtig lange richtig
viel besser
real tat das der beste stenzel den ich
je bekommen habe die anderen waren so
geist es kann zu waschen
ich habe immer so ein bisschen gefrustet
weil das nie so gut funktioniert hat
die jungen gioco altersgrenze
schwieriges thema ich habe sehr lange
sehr viel geraucht jetzt wollte ich
aufhören hat so gut funktioniert wie
eine woche dann einmal bier getrunken
dann lust bekommen wir auf eine
zigarette max war komplett dagegen
natürlich weil der wie gesagt in
gottverdammte ehrenmann ist und sich
darum sorgt dass man seinen freunden ist
jakob mein mitbewohner ist davon
überzeugt dass man sein leben in den
jungen jahren leben sollte und hat in
die andere richtung gearbeitet und
wollte gerne das mit dem rauchen
die leute würden ja auch vertrauen sie
wissen aber auch nicht warum die anderen
andere
kann es genau sind weil das das große
sagen wir die ich mache die kamera noch
ein bisschen weiter runter dann kann ich
nämlich april erwarte ich muss meinen
beiden doch eigentlich so halten wie das
ist wenn es entspannend ist aber weil
sie ja nicht oder sie hat nicht erlaubt
dass ich mich tätowieren aber es sollte
nicht so schlimm ist so ein monster
heimat und es gab so ein running gag
dass wir immer gesagt haben und lüge das
überhaupt erlaubt dass du egal was
machst und das hat für jemand
geschrieben
ja aber ich muss erst richtig schütteln
beide sind zur verschiedene stoffe drin
[Applaus]
peinlicherweise so richtig seit ich
anfangs 15 bin also fast eine schachtel
am tag oder freunde ich hatte ja dieses
youtube projekt geplant wo ich damit
komplett aufhören aber ich habe wie
gesagt nach dem dritten tag nicht mehr
gefilmt zwar ein bisschen los erinnerst
du dich an deine träume ja ich habe des
öfteren so traum tagebuch geführt um
klar zu träumen das hat auch eine zeit
lang ganz gut funktioniert aber da bin
ich nicht mehr drin
also klarträumen ist so dass man seine
träume kontrollieren kann und dafür ist
es ratsam wenn man alle seine träume die
man so hat aufschreibt und man kann da
richtig gut reinkommen und dann
funktioniert das richtig gut
dating macht mir jetzt diese maschine
muss die nadel rein fetzen
dann kann es erst mal wahrnehmen
mach du kannst du selbst einfach so
richtig ab machen
diese nadel selbst vielleicht noch
machen soll alles andere
klassische geschichte weiß es nicht ich
bin ja kein damit und dann einstecken
drei mal so ein bisschen genauer ein und
dann genauso drehen ja fertig und wenn
jetzt darauf tritt dann können wir
gucken dass mit der nadel funktioniert
[Musik]
sag mal
ich hatte noch nie
echt
[Musik]
keine ahnung wo man die weiter rein und
raus trend ist es wichtig also zu tief
nicht die sieht so sieht so aus als wird
die gar nicht weit raus kommen
damit kann ich doch gar nicht so
wirklich zustechen noch ganz gut ist
perfekt ok dann so heißt eigentlich wäre
das eigentlich anfangen weil am rhein
nachsehen leute geht es jetzt los
und wie gesagt ich übernehme die na'vi
musste ein strauß und das ist doch gar
keine farbe daran oder nee ich hab mit
jody immer das ding rein gesteckt dann
gedrückt und dann hat sich also werden
das rein getan dann gedrückt das darf
nur nicht auf den boden kommen weil so
spritzt das und man zieht sich die farbe
da so hoch siehst du hast ja keine
ahnung
es geht los ich hole das mikro glaube
ich ein stückchen hatte kurz ein
stückchen näher zu mir und rede hier so
und damit so soll ich mich noch ein
bisschen weiter weg drin
juckt nicht
irgendwie sieht das ganz komisch aus
dass hier so viel haut zeigen
das sieht wenn jetzt holt auf den stream
geht bin ich ich wäre würde ich mir denn
auch anschauen was ja einfach rein damit
ich sag's wie es ist jana hat noch nie
tätowiert aber ich bin ja
[Musik]
ich glaube die muss echt ein bisschen
weiter raus
die nadel muss müssen wir daraus
zuordnet alter sieht geisteskrankheit
aus da aber das sind so fein aus ich
muss eigentlich kunst lernen das ist es
muss eine lüge sein
kunst muss man nicht lernen ach du hast
was linien draufgemacht ne bisher nicht
los alter alle müssen hier irgendwie
lernen oder hausarbeit schreiben macht
das auf gar keinen fall
er wird mal komplett weg ob das da so
bleibt ich fühle mich wie alter
geisteskrank
wie kamst du zum rauchen ich habe ja ja
es ist echt so ist rauchen so viele aber
keine na ja ich sag ja nicht wer aber
weiß ich nicht ich habe angefangen weil
ich dachte es wäre cool mit 15 alle
meine kumpels haben auch irgendwie
angefangen zu rauchen
wir haben den ganzen tag draußen
rumgehangen immer sind immer so mit dem
roller und mit mofas rumgefahren im ort
haben uns immer beim rewe getroffen und
da haben alle geraucht das war ein
bisschen doof kann man sich ein beispiel
an hier deckt und soll dieses semester
dreimal in der uni
er hat die musik natürlich noch mal ganz
genau
ja wir zum klarträumen hätte ich auch
lust drauf da müsste es nur mal wieder
selber da reinkommen und das sehr viel
aufwand und so weiter und muss ich
wirklich bock drauf haben geile jana
roberto ja macht dass ich küsse dich
roberto
vorsätze fürs neue jahr ja sehr viel
videos produzieren
aber das hat nichts mit neuen jahr zu
tun nein ich glaube nicht
es fand das roberta in den chat schreibt
weil werte ist derjenige den ich mit dem
ich in frankreich das handwerkzeug
gestellt habt mit dem ich auf die idee
gekommen bin das zu machen und eine
gottverdammte montes
ja kommt nach köln kommen jetzt nach
köln um roberto ja das tattoo hat eine
riesige bedeutung für mich so wie alle
alle anderen die ich mir gemacht habe
stark
[Musik]
also es war ernst gemeint roberto
na hallo hier ist auch das sind ja was
soll ich dazu sagen
freunde ich bin es tut mir leid während
hier jana tätowiert ist es schwer für
mich und für sie zu sprechen
für jana sowieso und für mich auch weil
ich mich dadurch die ganze zeit bewegen
ich habe eine idee ich gucke einfach
auch nicht auf dass herr tur und wenn
wir dann durch sind dann schaue ich mir
das an
warum du wirst du dir so viele tattoos
weil ich so viele dinge haben die mir
etwas bedeuten
hallo ida hatte die freundin die
freundin die schwester von schindler ist
chelsea das wir werden einfach normales
desinfektionsmittel und so ja
tatsächlich also die stellen die man die
ganze zeit sieht würde ich halt von
niemandem machen lassen das
professionell macht das hier sind sachen
auf die ich lust habe ich finde dass
funny irgendwie selber das tätowieren
auszuprobieren und ich finde es außerdem
irgendwie fand sich von leuten
tätowieren zu lassen die auch wenig
erfahrung haben weil ja man könnte es
auch auf kunst aber das erstens nicht
dasselbe und zweitens finde ich das auch
cool die sachen die tattoos zu behalten
die
durch solche dummen situationen
entstanden sind
[Musik]
jahre hat was linie in den haag es ist
sehr wichtig dass die auf spotify alle
den song benjamins von vasco anhört der
hat nämlich fast 100.000 streams und die
sollte durch den anhören bevor der
100.000 hat weil dann könnt ihr sagen
ihr wart die war einer der ersten
[Musik]
doch nach selbst ein sehr großer verein
beispielsweise wir waren letztes in
amsterdam zusammen dabei auf dem konzert
von ihnen
und ja
und so meine ganzen freunde nennen dass
abiturienten rap das so deutsch also
weniger auf flex flex nico meego
beleidigungen gegangen wird sondern mehr
auf irgendwelche dinge die vielleicht
nicht so gut laufen oder so oder ist
eine gute frage für das juicy fragt
wärst du auch so entspannt wenn deine
kinder sich später selbst zu wehren
wollen das können wir mal mein vater
fragen der mit sicherheit gerade
zuschauer oder schon abgeschaltet hat
weil es viel zu viel stress ist dass
sich das anzuschauen wenn ich nicht geil
irgendwie keine ahnung zumindest jetzt
nicht aber
jenny gibt schauer zum herbst an unsere
klick ja das echt krass wir haben uns
alle quasi dieses jahr so richtig
kennengelernt irgendwie und haben sehr
viel zusammen erlebt also wirklich
überdurchschnittlich und ja brauchen
heinz reitbauer gottverdammte man könnt
ihr euch auf jeden fall alle mal anhören
ist einer den habe ich auch die sie erst
kennengelernt oder nicht kennengelernt
aber auch spotify gefunden
crazy du lass dich doch mal von kelly
tolerieren
[Musik]
muss was war nochmal also ja ich könnte
das ja eigentlich echt fanny sich so von
allen leuten aus der gruppe irgendwas
tätowieren zu lassen
ich glaube ich würde ich das nicht wir
könnten also mein gott beste video idee
was denn vor kurzem geheimnisse und dann
so zweierteams ist krass aber das kannst
du einmal nahm dann alleine rum ja aber
nur so in seinem blog zum kleinen
parcours alles zack raß ja wer weiß
vielleicht kommt es zustande wenn das
ferne
wer gehört zu eurer klickt ist es
schwierig zu sagen die sind gefühlt im
letzten jahr super viele leute nach köln
gekommen inklusive uns und das ist so
ein crysis riesig aber zum engsten kreis
gehören marco das ist ja da ich jakob
max und sebastian greene l sowie die
gruppe heißt j mich aus weil wir immer
freestyle kicken alters eco-mode sorry
ich habe nun ein kleiner aber es perfekt
weil es so scribble mäßig ist
erdmann findet deine video.de gut ja
sehr gut
ich hoffe man dass für jack ich darf ich
darf nicht sagen
magst bitte gebt euch gebt uns mit den
updates aus der uni
und das treibt einzelnen zettel mit
zurückkommen sollen 1 in den chat wenn
maxim jakob endlich die uni schwänzen
sollen mehr mehr mehr mehr mehr
sehr gut roberto robert werner du musst
roberta kennenlernen der mode begeistert
und sehr
ja aber ich kann nicht beschreiben wie
ist das ein toller mensch ist die leute
waren dann ab auszulöschen
ja ja ja ich glaube das sind zu viele
sounds und weil weniger geredet wird als
vorher aber dafür bleiben jetzt die
realen leute hier
ich bin richtig los wenn keine sachen in
den chat geschrieben werden wenn man
anfangen würde zu streamen jetzt so ohne
dass man zuschauer die irgendwas in den
chat schreiben würden wäre es richtig
hart alter ja
nein
ich wollte die ganze darauf dass ihr
mann eine gute frage ich steche ich dich
stellen kann
die bist du in die clique gegangen
du darfst dir ganz trainer
[Musik]
wir haben sie es gab die gruppe nicht in
die ich bin ja in die ich reingekommen
bin sondern als ich max und jakob und
sebastian kennengelernt habe das waren
die drei die sich vorher schon kannten
weil jakob und max zusammen studieren
und sebastian hund max geschwister sind
ob wir es liegt ja also max max und
sebastian sind keine zwillinge sind aber
geschwister
die beiden kannten sich natürlich max
hat jakob kennengelernt
ich habe max kennen gelernt und dann
waren wir schon vier und jakob hat dann
irgendwann zwei monate später marco mal
mitgebracht und es war liebe auf den
ersten blick und genau und dann alle
denken wir wären so kranke alkis weil
die ganze zeit
naja dazu passend die frage von jenny
bestes getränktem feiern wir ja ist ja
wenn halte sehr sehr dem bier
verschrieben
ich weiß
wodka oder kelly und ich habe so ein
ritual dass wir jedes mal wenn wir
zusammen feiern gehen in wodka soda
zusammen trinken ja das auch ziemlich
nahe
aber ansonsten auch hier
[Musik]
wurde sie schon auf der straße
angesprochen werden
tatsächlich im bootshaus das erste mal
ja ja jetzt am wochenende ja da hat mich
so eine person gefragt können wir ein
foto machen nicht mehr so etwas fragt
warum sie so gesagt ja ich will das cool
was du machst und ich war sehr
verwundert war aber richtig
komisch irgendwie ein komisches gefühl
weiß ich auch nicht was ich also cool so
würde ich auch machen wahrscheinlich
wenn ich irgendjemanden sehen würde den
ich gut finde aber es war komisch weil
ich nicht das gefühl natürlich nicht von
mir selber das gefühl hatte sich lohnen
würde mit mir ein bild zu machen
bester live aus köln ist natürlich ganz
leicht zu beantworten das ist für die bi
der besten ja am spät die sitzung schon
aber wir haben keine spät ist im kiosk
mehrere kioske und da kann man aber auch
gut sitzen
[Musik]
könnt ihr euch vorstellen längere zeit
wie ganzes leben
wir drei haben tatsächlich alles von
meiner zeit haben wir
geil freunde willkommen
dem kommen nähern uns dem ende
naja du jetzt macht das sowie
installiert ja da ja einfach drauf ich
guck noch nicht okay das funktioniert
nicht gut
auf der k
nehmen natürlich nicht aber
[Musik]
weil sie nicht wann der stream zu ende
ist das entscheiden wir wie wir lust
haben
farbige tattoo ist es nicht so meins es
gibt keine richtlinien für bunte titel
farbe in deutschland das heißt jemand
weiß nicht was in diesen farben drin ist
in dem buch das ist sehr schlecht
das sollte man sich auch nicht und in
den dunklen ist nicht meine ist keiner
von uns vertragen aber ich bin auch
glaube ich der einzige der viele
elektronische musik die anderen sind
eher im hip hop verschrieben mal
erklären wie die silvesterfeier abläuft
ja also im endeffekt ist es einfach nur
eine party die von ein paar jungs ist
die ich im urlaub kennengelernt habe und
mein bruder da läuft haus und so
tanzbare elektronische musik die auf
platte aufgelegt wird also ziemlich nice
und dann ist es einfach eine party wo
coole mucke läuft und man ins neue jahr
feiert mehr gibt es dazu nicht zu sagen
für 20 euro kann man bier frei trinken
und irgendwelche anderen getränke steht
aber alles in dem event
[Musik]
hahaha findet projekt ist richtig dumm
habe ich nachdem ich den link gepostet
hat kein einziges mal weiter verfolgt
muss ich mich jetzt aber rein hängen
aber über diesen einen link ich habe nur
diesen einen link ja geteilt und denn in
meiner in story gepackt darüber wurden
schon airports gekauft im tablet einen
amazon feier tv stick ich muss gleich
mal rein gucken was das kostet was es
kostet wie viel dabei herum gekommen ist
sehr viel so doku kram wenn ich was
gucke marquez brownlee sein
amerikanischer technik youtuber und ab
und zu ein paar reactions aber
mittlerweile immer weniger also ich
gucke auch allgemein immer weniger
youtube-videos was gut was ich gut und
schlecht zugleich finde ich weiß nicht
genau eigentlich ohne ohne das werten zu
wollen ich gucke einfach weniger
youtube-videos in letzter zeit
ja es wird sogar zwei mal bestellt ich
lese mal kurz vor was alles über den
link bestellt wurde
richtig crazy ein fahrrad licht apple
airports echte stimmt dann irgendwelche
sachen die ich nicht kenne leider mord
mord im orient ein buch doktorhut ging
zweimal feier tv stick feier hd tablet
also ich muss kurz gucken was das ist
eine steckdose
ja völlig crazy über diesen einen link
einfach
fertig entschuldigung ich wechsel gleich
das bild wieder und dann ist auch der
ton wieder synchron zwei minuten sowie
drei minuten ja geil
das aber ist fein
ich glaube das liegt daran dass die
nadel nicht so weit raus kommt warum ist
kann immer so inaktiv das ist eine gute
frage das müsst ihr ihn selber fragen
aber ich kann soviel sagen dass max
damit auch nicht zufrieden ist also der
feiert das genauso wenig wie ihr dass er
so wenig macht was tätowiert jana einen
skateboard hier sind die leute die sind
die verschiedenen sachen bestellt haben
schreiben mit ja wir hatten ähnlich
stellt ihren mann
also ja das ist privat dass man sehen
kann was bestellt wurde
aber man sieht nicht von wem das
bestellt wurde also weil sie nicht man
weiß dass unter den 1000 leuten die auf
den link geklickt haben die und die
sachen bestellt wurden aber man weiß
natürlich nicht an wen die verschickt
wurden oder wer die bestellt hat ich
glaube unbekannte leute tätowieren macht
keiner von uns zumindest nicht bevor
merz ist im jahr ihre ausbildung gemacht
hat dann dann kann jahres und dann wirst
du bestimmt auch einfach so leute
studieren oder aber das werdet ihr noch
mitbekommen
[Musik]
marco alle wollen
aber es ist finde ich auch schwierig
neben apple eigentlich noch der macht
glaube ich laden video sagt nein
videos sonst werde er auch hier
so einzelnen chat wenn jakob marx
endlich aus der uni kommen sollen
[Musik]
aber ist es tatsächlich richtig
entspannt ich finde das sehr ich bin
sehr wie soll ich das formulieren
ich bin froh darüber dass youtube nicht
meine haupteinkommensquelle ist oder so
oder das ist ja gar keine
einkommensquelle aber dass ich damit
erst so frisch gestartet habt weil ich
bin so frei gefühlt ich bekommen bei ein
paar leuten somit dass sie
schwierigkeiten damit haben noch die
sachen zu machen auf die sie selber
wirklich lust haben und das ist ja auch
klar dass wenn das irgendwann so ernst
wird dass es der job ist dass man damit
schwierigkeiten bekommt aber da ich das
nicht habe kann ich mich hier so
hinsetzen jana tätowiert mich es
passiert gar nicht so super viel aber
die leute die bock haben schauen einfach
zu und es geht irgendwie um nichts
das ist echt extrem entspannt das freut
mich sehr dass es so gut ist dort keine
tattoos
was war jana als erster eindruck von dir
keine ahnung das kann ich gar nicht
sagen weil sie am tätowieren war ist
aber mein erster eindruck von jana ich
war erstmal komplett überfordert mit
ihrem auftreten weil sie so so das
allererste mal als ich ihn getroffen
habe war sie so super aktiv und
aufgedreht und das ist auch fein aber in
dem moment war ich damit ein bisschen
über max und ich haben hier für die uni
uns auch das erste mal getroffen und da
warst du auch da und du warst richtig so
abspeisen und am tanzen und hast mich
direkt so in die gruppe mit einbezogen
was natürlich mega korrekt war
aber ich stand also ein jahren hat mich
so an angepackt und mich drum herum
getanzt und ich daher wird vergehen weil
die worte nicht wie ich mich verhalten
soll und dass so ziemlich so war das
aber es liegt safe daran dass die na ja
es liegt daran dass die nadel einfach
nicht so weit es geht
aber ich glaube dass eigentlich find das
letzte derby gesagt dass acht gut ist
für so linien und so echt ja dann verein
ohne sind stream ag
aber ich mag das sehr
wenn es so ist sonst würde ich das auch
nicht machen ja ist perfekt kommen hier
wie das aussieht also lassen oder sich
mal diese linie versuchen
das war geil wenn wir wissen würden wie
wir das weiter heraus bekommen aber wir
können ja auch easy kassiert knall das
einfach da rein und wenn das nicht
funktioniert dann machen wir das einfach
die tage irgendwann wenn wir wissen wie
wir es weiter raus bekommen oder so
guten abend marvin wasser gottverdammten
man ja wirklich weil so viele leute
zugucken die ich privat kenne das ist
sehr schön
lebt ihr gerade euer bestes leben ich
kann es dir nicht sagen ich hab nur 1
jetzt war alles andere als lieb gemeint
das war eigentlich witzig gemeint aber
es kam nicht an
zwar für gewöhnlich lache ich sogar sehr
also lasse ich eigentlich immer selber
über meine witze aber nicht mal das hat
funktioniert
relativ wenig angst davor dass sich das
irgendwie entzündet oder so weil wir
ziemlich gut desinfizierten jana alles
mit handschuhen macht und wir also
eigentlich in keiner stelle wir mit
irgendwas und desinfizierten daran
gegangen sind also nehmen
naja ich studiere noch aber solange
keine klausuren bei mir in diesem online
system erscheinen so lange kommt nicht
um die und safe nächstes jahr
[Musik]
sie läuft die mutter eigentlich noch das
könnte man den chat schreiben kann es
nicht herum
bin momentan ein bisschen lost in meinem
leben chips keine ahnung immer als ich
lost war in meinem leben hat es mir
geholfen
irgendwas zu suchen ein hobby zu suchen
wo ich richtig viel energie reinstecken
kann ich hatte das tatsächlich die ist
ja auch dass ich irgendwie mit allem
unzufrieden war und so und dann bin ich
für zwei monate nach frankreich gegangen
habe gar nichts gemacht und angefangen
mich zu tätowieren und ja und fotos
wieder mehr zu machen ohne dass
irgendwelche jobs waren und das hat mir
super gut geholfen
ich weiß nicht wie alt bist also reisen
weg raus aus dem normalen leben oder ein
neues hobby suchen oder so
geil
ok freunde ich zeige euch das fertige
tattoo aber ist genau das was wir wollen
weil meine anderen tattoos die ich auf
den beinen haben sie natürlich in dem
selben stil
[Musik]
ich muss schneller wechsel von der camp
so freunde
ich muss ganz kurz den akku meiner
kamera wechseln und wenn ihr zwei
minuten meter darf oder so oder so was
gibt man muss kurzum sie weiter
unterhalten ich muss auch sagen abwarten
was die alleinunterhalter alles schlecht
im kurs sagt das 0 3 bei base camps soll
jetzt schreibt alle fragen markieren den
song im besten fall habt ihr seine songs
umgehört was kommt benjamins conference
on track on track falls ihr nicht
gehörten jetzt parallel an und alle
anderen können nicht welche fragen und
tipps um sich solche reisen finanzieren
zu können arbeiten gehen irgendwo
hingehen wo man nichts für die reise
bezahlt ich war bedient nach frankreich
gegangen und habe für kost und logie da
gearbeitet also dann hilft man den
irgendwie im camp alltag hält das camp
sauber und kann dafür kostenlos da im
zelt leben und essen oder so
[Musik]
reisen ist leider schwierig wenn man
arbeiten muss ja vorher arbeiten
kündigen und dann reisen gehen und dann
wiederkommen
das ist leider nicht aber ich habe
tatsächlich kann ich euch jetzt mal
erzählen
ich habe tatsächlich auch eine reise
nach dem abi gemacht und da sich auch
fünf monate vollzeit gearbeitet und
quasi kein leben gehabt und dann habe
ich das ganze ersparte geld genutzt
sondern so lange reisen gegangen wie ich
geld hatte ebenso nach dem abi so passen
die kannst du kurz nach rechts und werde
ich jetzt das ergebnis der letzten
halben stunde zeigen
es ist soweit freunde
ich selber noch nicht gesehen da übels
nice ich bin ich bin nur bvb tor jana
ich bin richtig happy damit weil das ja
weil das mega fight ist also das so fein
wie ich das bei den anderen nämlich
nicht hinbekommen habe
da hab ich dann immer so richtig fett
die linie gemacht
ja gut aber wir technisch so könnt ihr
das sehen könnt ihr das sehen ist
skateboard sieht man das
gehören könnte
ja ganz gut und wurde noch im recht
fragen was gestellt ja ich war gerade
mal
bist du bist ja es war wunderschön
ich mache jetzt aber glaube ich noch
zehn minuten noch mal schnell ja sehr
gerne noch zehn minuten irgendwelche
fragen oder so weil mir das recht bock
macht und dann schauen wir mal
[Musik]
diana ist ein naturtalent hätten das
nachsehen könnte
naja ich bin tatsächlich auch also real
tor sehr zufrieden sagt das nicht weil
die jahner das gemacht hat sondern
einfach so besser club in köln
wahrscheinlich reineke fuchs kommen was
geht ein bisschen weiter das video sagst
es aus welchem land kommt vasco
natürlich italien
wir haben natürlich auch schon gemeinsam
seine heimat nicht seine heimat aber
sein heimatland besucht ausschnitte
davon findet ihr im jahresausblicks
video
es war verrückt alle die ich sehen wo
wir in den bus gesprungen sind sind
auszuteilen und natürlich ist der fokus
wieder auf
stadt oder land mich statt
für mich in jungen jahren statt und
langfristig safe saves echos land marco
benutzte bartl mein friseur motivation
zu zehn sesselbahn benutzt das immer
wenn ich fertig bin aber ich leider noch
nicht ich habe es vor ja wann kommt der
nächste patrick marco ist hat natürlich
schon fleißig tracks geschrieben und
hüpft jetzt bald wieder ins studio und
dann kommen neue banger sekt auf samstag
ist gleich gar nichts machen 111 ist
gleich arbeiten und dafür kostenlos
wohnen und es kommt darauf an die haben
verschiedene jobs aber es ist sehr
schwierig da an jobs zu kommen für die
man keine ausbildung braucht weil das
halt super viele machen wollen
wo findet man solche angebote einfach
googeln nach irgendwelchen deutschen
camps in anderen ländern und surfcamps
jugendcamps jugendreisen alles das gibt
es für ski fahren surfen einfach so
irgendwo und dann einfach alle anschauen
irgendwie eine eine bewerbung fertig
machen eine mail aufsetzen mit
motivationsschreiben und dann einfach an
alle gleichzeitig rausschicken einfacher
geht's eigentlich nicht hallo du dir ja
soll ich dir zeigen ist es wunderschön
geworden
ich bedanke mich vielmals viele liter
maschine machen du musst sagen wie ich
mich positionieren muss ist eigentlich
gut bisschen mehr vielleicht ein
bisschen ist nicht wirklich okay jetzt
jetzt jetzt ein bisschen näher
vielleicht ist jetzt halt leider
naja zeigt ihren bildschirmen es ist
eben leider verzogen weil ich mich auf
die zehenspitzen gestellt habe aber das
wunderbar gewonnen immerhin zählt mit
einem smiley tätowiert
januar ist am schneiden die hat leider
deine pops nicht gesehen und natürlich
wieder und schafft so ich war vor dir
jetzt noch drei fragen und war es das
aber es war sehr schön und es hat sehr
viel spaß gemacht aber jetzt jeden
advent das sage ich jetzt einfach so
jeden advent werde ich ein livestream
machen mit coolen leuten und irgendwas
nächstes mal zu glühwein selber machen
oder irgendwas backen oder so habe ich
richtig bock drauf
ihr könnt meine stellt nur noch ein paar
gute fragen und dann wieder drei fragen
und dann beenden wir das ganze
ok ich probiere jetzt ganz schnell noch
zwei minuten alle fragen zu beantworten
die reinkommen die handy hülle von jana
ist serge von sweet boy blondie stadt
ich habe einen bruder markus einzelkind
jakob und max sind in der uni fantreffen
nein das finde ich irgendwie ein
bisschen komisch wenn wir uns sehen dann
lies wenn nicht dann nicht
ja weiß ich auch nicht ob das eine gute
idee es direkt nach dem abi zu studieren
musste gucken wenn du nach einem jahr
merkst dass du keinen bock mehr als
zuerst halt wieder auf ich will es elf
kinder haben marco du auch sein magst du
bist ja wir feiern alle bis 11 das hast
du mit dem handy angestellt ist es mir
die ganze zeit also mehrfach auf den
boden gefallen
man kommt ja aus der uni weiß ich nicht
glaubt 21 uhr oder so wo findet man
sollte travel work work angebote google
ja wenn du im deutschen camp österreich
das dass du deutsch reden kannst
meistens ja ich schreibe auf install
zurück in den meisten fällen marke von
den nadeln das war irgendwas gutes jolie
hat so richtig guten kram gehabt da
hatte ich kurz schnell das gefällt den
besten surfen oder schiebe ziemliches
notruf waren schifoan weltbesten seines
mega schwierig gerade weil man nur so
kurz im jahr immer surfen geht dann kann
man das quasi nicht so richtig lernen
aber skifahren geht es schon besser
ja ich habe die letzten anderthalb
wochen oder in den letzten zwei wochen
anderthalb wochen begann gelegt waren
eis habe nicht viel besser gefühlt
jetzt lebt probiert aber so vegetarisch
zu leben so freunde vielen dank fürs
zuschauen das hat sehr viel spaß gemacht
1 in den chat wenn ihr auch sehr viel
spaß hatte vielen dank an jana vielen
dank an marco check die alle auf ins
toraus wenn ihr bei mir auf internet
findet ihr die alle irgendwo verlinkt es
war sehr fein
ich werde auf insider sagen wann ich
vistream es hat auf jeden fall sehr viel
spaß gemacht das war nicht das letzte
mal
vielen vielen dank macht es gut kurs
weiß